what part does the mayor play in
politics and in in the city what does
actually the mayor do
uh in the city it appears to me that
over the last maybe 20 years when amer
is elected
they kind of uh disappear you know you
see more of the mayor in batman movies
than you do in in real life
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
gentlemen father's day is just around
the corner and our friends of manscaped
are here to ensure that all the father
figures out there are looking daddy
material this june so manscape's
performance package 4.0 which includes
their signature lawnmower 4.0 is the
perfect bundle to tackle any and all old
man hair from head to toe the this right
here is no dad joke treat him and
yourself and join the four million men
worldwide who trust manscaped with this
exclusive offer you can get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code omghi
at manscape.com trust me his dad bod
will thank you
our guest today
called me and said
is this the place where people go
and speak freely and i said yes yes sir
it is and you
can come on and speak freely whenever
you want
the fact that he is not in uniform
tells me
that
he's ready to get down
and tell the truth and it's not about
his position it's about him i believe as
a man
in the business of law enforcement in in
one of the biggest cities
in the world who you know um
gets vilified and
and and
targeted because of his position of
power
not really about
the job that he's done
so with that grant
beautiful i mean did you introduce our
guest absolutely joining us you know
what gayle you do at coda because i mean
sir
well i am honored to have the privilege
to introduce
the sheriff of los angeles county
the man the myth the legend
mr alex villanueva sheriff welcome
to oh my god hi podcast it's an honor to
be here with you and
of course you know i'm a loyal follower
anyway
well thank you guilford and george for
the invitation it's great to see all of
you and i'm
unfamiliar with a man in the middle
right there
oh howdy i'm grant i produce the show
you know what i think the statute of
limitations can can has run out but he
sold a lot of stolen property out of his
house in high school
okay uh alex
um
with the election coming up right the
election is coming up election is coming
up um um
uh give us your uh give us where you are
today where you are as a man and as a as
a sheriff today
well today we're doing what we're
supposed to be doing i had a meeting at
a press conference downtown l.a talking
about the mta and talking about getting
all the homeless off the train so people
can ride the train without stepping over
bodies you know common sense things
and my opponents were busy doing a
kabuki theater at loyola marymount law
school talking about phantom gangs
so you can't really
you know
juxtapose the two positions right there
you know that that's uh
it's it's that's right you know
one of the issues i think that
we talked about was the homeless crisis
in in in the los angeles in los angeles
county
um
talk to us a little bit about um
how how the situation has
has become
i mean really clearly you see i mean
alex i mean you know you see all the
people around what what where are we as
a city in combating this and and how
much
of
how much of what's out there is because
i think people are talking about people
who are mentally ill which which
yeah how much
what's the situation with the
homelessness in los angeles um right now
well right now we're in pretty bad shape
we're the nation's capital for
homelessness a full
of the entire nation's homeless are now
in la county
and that is literally by design because
we have the county the city of la
they've all decided one not to do
anything about the homeless throw a lot
of money at the homeless industrial
complex
and then are amazed that it's exploding
and yeah great weather great dope and
free stuff everywhere what's not to like
about coming to la right right exactly
um yeah so so
what are some of the
can we break down you think just in a
category of
of how many people are homeless
the pandemic i'm sure activated a lot of
people who are just kind of living from
paycheck to patriot which is more common
than i think people think and then
people who are
i mean listen man i mean it's it's it's
got to be
for a better lack of a better term it's
a bit of um
you know everybody's so sensible what
they say but if you were somebody that
was living paycheck to paycheck and you
ended up on the street you would have to
consider yourself in another world to be
a homeless person now right
yes and we're looking at about 70
percent of our homeless and this is
about 80 000 people that are on the
streets right now
about 70 of them suffer either mental
illness drug abuse or a combination of
both right so that leaves about 30
percent that might be victims economic
circumstances
they might be drifters that like the
lifestyle and i've actually heard that
from actual homeless people that they're
there by their own free will
and people that are caught up in losing
their job in the pandemic illnesses that
puts them out of work bankruptcies bad
relationships but those are the people
that are actually the easiest to gain to
get shelter because they want to get a
roof over their head they're not here to
make a statement by i'm homeless and i
love it or i'm you know just going to
live in a tent and take a crap on the
sidewalk right these are people that
actually want to improve their
circumstances
and they're the easiest to get shelter
it's a 70 percent that's the harder
problem
but also you have to say that there's
there's an element of
the people who live in these
neighborhoods who either leave bikes on
their porch
who get packages delivered to their
house during the day
who leave who leave things in their car
and who get their cars broken into and
their bikes taken and their packages
taken taken
and they
will say the crime is coming up but
as a citizen or somebody that owns a
home or somebody that parks their car on
the street you can't leave things in
your car that you know if somebody sees
they're going to take
yeah if it's not if it's not nailed down
you know as they say
[Laughter]
so you know so
the amount of you know people who are on
neighbor next door or on citizen app and
who
will never will never tell anybody when
they're doing a nice job or a good job
they only want to talk about how bad
things are but also in crime and in
homelessness and in mental illness and
drugs and people who just are happy to
be out there
the people who are out there also have a
responsibility
uh to maybe want to
uh uh make their lives a little better i
think if you're mentally ill you you
don't know where you are anyways but but
um how how do we get go about to
separate um the wheat from the shaft if
you would say
well that's that's a tough problem we
have right now because we have the
willful and we have the ones that are
unable
and by mental illness or substance abuse
they're so far gone
and for that crowd we need to have the
we need to build up the capacity we
don't have residential treatment for
people with mental illness in fact we
just keep closing
mental hospitals and then we wonder why
everyone's on the street walking around
like zombies although we actually
created the problem back in the 60s and
70s
if uh if you're old enough to remember
that and we've never built that capacity
at the community level so now we're
paying the price for the sins of you
know three decades ago
and it's come you know we gotta solve
that right there okay i might have a i
might have
one possible solution
if basketball season was starting today
could we give all the homeless people
out there clippers season tickets so
they have a place to sit
and to sleep
while
well
while the
but
clip
you saying there's enough empty seat
capacity there it might be
you know and you know it smells like pee
already a little bit in there um
no no i'm kidding but i think gail wants
to do the whole hour and a half and not
say a word
so no that's that that's not true at all
i'm following the bosses leaving
and also with uh with the mental
facilities that are closing with the
hospitals that are closing
um
you know do you do you do you think that
there's an element of people who want to
stall you out because there is an
election coming up and potentially have
you removed that sheriff
oh yeah definitely they want to write it
out and see and hope
that they'll get someone in office who's
going to be their puppet they'll be a
sheriff on a leash they'll have them
roll over and do tricks
and they won't do anything they'll never
set a foot like on the venice boardwalk
or call out the failures of county
government
but i'm not here to pretend things are
working great but it's not working hey
that ain't working let's fix it and i
think we can but the first step is just
like an alcoholic you gotta admit you
got a problem
the county and the city never wants to
admit that well you know there was a
problem uh i haven't seen conflict like
this since baxter ward and peter pitches
and when baxter was with the board of
supervisors
they bumped heads but peter pitches
eventually won
he was the solution he won out
and the board of supervisors acquiesced
and we're hoping with your victory
coming up that maybe there'll be less
bumping of heads and people will learn
that the right thing is being done
all it takes is three that's it the rule
of three
i think we have two supervisors that are
now supporting law enforcement and
that's katherine barger and that's um
janice han from the fourth district the
third district is open so let's see who
gets out of there the first district is
hilda solis she's running for reelection
she refuses to campaign to do um
candidate forums or debates with anybody
we've never seen one
i don't know why she gets a free pass on
that one
but uh i think between the two we're
gonna get at least one more vote
with someone who's gonna support just
basic law and order common sense stuff
so i think we got a positive future
ahead why do the rest of the board of
supervisors not want to
not want to do anything for the city
they've embraced the whole thing about
law enforcement is bad and let's defund
law enforcement they want to replace
cops with community-based organizations
that basically are going to contribute
to their re-election campaigns it's all
about rewarding their family and friends
with contracts with service providers
that's how you make seven billion
dollars disappear over 10 years and the
homeless population explodes and you
wonder what happened well
they ran away with the money and we're
left holding the bag
certainly what you did in venice uh by
cleaning up over there
uh have they started coming back or have
we been successful in what you
accomplished out there with the
sheriff's department
we've been successful in keeping the
boardwalk itself clear but we've had a
couple of migrations into like
centennial park in a block
inland from the boardwalk
so venice is not out of the woods by any
stretch but it did show that when we
work together we can produce results we
just got to scale up
the initiative
county-wide and remember
fema when there's a hurricane or a big
thing they'll house 50 000 people in a
weekend yeah
and red cross international red cross
you get a war in a million refugees
right they get them housing and yet here
we are struggling with 83 000 people we
wonder why we can't get the job done
you know i think you think the homeless
problem is getting worse when you see
a two-story homeless comp like the guy
had a tuesday i don't know how he did
two stories because you know they they
were trying to talk to me so i'll be
right down you know i don't think i've
never seen a homeless two-story
uh house i don't know how i got the
boxes to to just but but
you know they're they're getting i mean
not to make not to make light but i make
light of everything um that
you know
they they become these camps under the
un under underpasses and that and at off
ramps and
um a lot of those people that you see
are are very young i'm not even sure if
they're necessarily panhandlers anymore
that i don't see a lot of people
you know at omrans on
on-ramps asking for money i don't really
see that as much as i see more of the
encampments that people that homeless
people stay at
yeah i see more people selling oranges
and flowers than i do people panhandling
that should kind of tell you something
right there if you want to work you can
god bless those people that have to they
get out there and sell oranges and
flowers
uh they're trying in fact
george i just heard a statistic last
week there's two jobs available for
everyone who wants to work in the united
states right now two
and then you got people that walk for 2
000 miles to come to l.a yeah they come
to work we don't see them living under
the freeway
you know that's a very that's a very
good point that uh
that those people uh
uh work every day they're not asking for
help they would be embarrassed to to to
be able to work and live outside you
know i was working uh part-time
a year and a half ago i've been done
department of uh
children family services and right
across the street from the building we
were occupying there was a homeless
person are there a few almost camping
out there is it female but i was shocked
no it was a male okay and
he had a nickname they call everybody
called him kong on the block
and
i was
shocked one day standing out on the
corner a ups truck drove up
to make a delivery he was having stuff
delivered to him
right there on his corner
and and how they do this
yeah it's amazing yeah uh um you know in
los angeles i think i think
um
the the our history is more towards
lapd and the and the sheriff i mean the
captain of the lapd the
is that what they call him the captain
who's the general gates the police chief
the police chief of police the chief of
police was the guy who was taking all
the heat in los angeles through all the
years
and the sheriff seemed to me like i was
telling gil that the sheriff seemed to
be
the least aggressive of the of the crime
fighting units between the lapd and then
be real from cyprus still came in here
and said oh no man the sheriffs are the
ones that you don't mess with we didn't
lie to the sheriffs when they came into
the neighborhood we told them the truth
because we respected them because they
let us live and they weren't in here
just to kind of push people around and
be but but they had so i i learned that
the sheriff's in los angeles have the
you know respect of the community but
lapd was the the chief and all that
stuff that but how did how did how is
this not an issue with the los angeles
police department
and how are you it can yeah it's kind of
evolved over time remember because we
had daryl gates back in the 80s and 90s
the rodney king riots that was probably
the probably the peak of that whole
enforcement culture the warrior thing us
versus them and i think from that there
was definitely a turn in the other
direction hey let's start working be
part of the community building
relationships so now it's all about a
guardian model it's about engagement
building relationships not sexy stuff
that's made for a 60-minute tv uh you
know crime fighting thing on tv
but it's actually what works because now
we're perceived as the ones who
protecting the community as opposed to
uh an army of occupation
and and not knocking any picking on
anybody but you mentioned darrell gates
daryl gates stood up to the
city government back then he protected
his men and women
uh
chief moore
isn't as vociferous as daryl gates was
and seems to acquiesce to whatever
city wants him to do
and so it becomes problematic uh for the
members of the lapd
and we're all in a business together
yeah that that's always an issue now
today with the appointed chiefs of
police they can't operate with the
freedom that elected sheriffs because
you guys are you're my boss literally
there's no one in between you and i i
just got to figure what 10 million
people want but going back to gates
as conservative and he's been portrayed
he had the foresight way back in the 70s
special order 40
that he was not going to be involved in
immigration enforcement
him and though he understood it was
about public safety
so you gotta you know he's easy to
criticize but at the same time he was
very
you know forward thinking in terms of
what's the relationship between law
enforcement and the community
yeah that's that's exactly right um how
did how did you become an enemy of the
los angeles times
oh that was real easy um
as soon as i took office one i defeated
their uh endorsed candidate so that was
my cardinal sin one right there
because they want a sheriff who's
subordinate to the board of supervisors
so by me being independent of the board
i'm public enemy number one right there
and now
in fact when we took ice out of the
jails that was a big deal nationally
except the l.a times just did an
absolute blanket on it as if we never
did anything
to this day they had an article out
yesterday talking about my time in
office they could not even mention it
once
because it's not part of their policy
because they've crafted this false
narrative that they've been working on
for years to try to sell to the public
that somehow i'm wrong when i'm actually
just doing my job that the way i'm
supposed to
and i'll work with the board but i don't
work for the board i work for you guys
thank you
um
how many people sit on the board
we got five
and um
do those five get along i mean they have
a lot of power the board of supervisors
seems to have a lot of power in los
angeles
oh there that's why they've been called
the five little kings forever
because they have unchecked power they
have no oversight
they have no transparency they're not
accountable to anybody but get
re-elected every four years
and remember they're both the
legislative branch of government and the
executive branch of government combined
into one
so you want to talk about ultimate power
trip
it's them yet they're the ones that will
turn around and be moan for me for
example is sheriff
yeah that's really sounds like the job
that that somebody would want to have
other than being the mayor of los
angeles i've been being who are the five
people who are the five border
supervisors
we have um
illustrates district one
holly mitchell district two
sheila kuhl who's retiring district
three so it's open now in the election
the uh john is han in district four and
catherine barger in district five those
are your your five little kings right
there
do the people who you know have have
elections throughout all throughout the
united states
do the people who who vote and who do
not vote do they understand that
an election is an election and they're
all important that just like all i'll
all vote only when it's maybe the
presidential election but do people the
the everyday citizen understand that all
of these elections matter
you know what the the amount of uh of
information or education of the
electorate
a lot of people don't really understand
the role of local government for example
they're all keen on who's yelling at who
in sacramento or in d.c a lot of
political theater but the ones that
actually makes or break their community
is a supervisor their local mayor their
local city council
those are the local d.a for example or
like the one we have that doesn't do
anything
that's the ones that affect your quality
of life you get it gets the least amount
of attention
and i'll go a step further than that
sheriff i don't believe that half the
residents of
la county that live in incorporated
areas
understand that they vote
for the sheriff and that they vote for
the district attorney they believe
because they're incorporated city they
have a chief of police they have nothing
to do with it they do yeah it's every
resident in los angeles every voting
resident in los angeles county and that
word has to get out
yeah they need to join this is very true
yes they need to understand that it's
not just you know in november every four
years but every every election and also
if you're unhappy with what's happening
in your district pick up the phone and
call and call your counsel person
oh yes we posted the numbers for the
board of supervisors online oh they hate
it
because they don't want to hear from
their constituents
especially when they screw up which is
most of the time so uh yeah
um
you know a lot of people hear the the
term defund the police you know um
explain to everybody what that that term
means to defund the police
well the way the term was generated
after the george floyd protest
you have a group like uh different type
of anti-government groups antifa crowd
you have the anarchists they want to
defund law enforcement they fact they
call the abolitionist movement they want
to get rid of law enforcement entirely
they want to get rid of the jails they
want to get rid of the prisons
and i guess they're assuming that
everyone's going to sing kumbaya when
this happens and they want to re they
call it reinvesting in the community
but the average taxpayer say wait a
minute i'm breaking my butt
paying property taxes half of it goes
towards public education
and then you look at the county budget
the overwhelming majority goes to health
and human services
and welfare all these different things
we get 10 roughly the county budget 10
and we're severely understaffed the way
it is right now so defunding means
you're going to pay the consequences for
someone else's social experiment
i think i just read some place this
morning or yesterday where
they're now realizing that maybe
defunding the police was the wrong move
and hopefully after the elections things
will
get back that let's refund the police
and get them some what
they desperately need and that's money
for more cops money for more programs
out on the streets that's going to help
keep our residents safe
yes look at look at president biden
he's been on tv now all of this month
saying fund fund fund law enforcement
but our board hasn't got that memo for
some reason it's kind of weird because
they're from the same party i don't get
it mm-hmm
um
yeah
i was gonna say i forgot
um
oh so so what what what part does the
mayor play in politics and in in the
city what does actually the mayor do
uh in the city it appears to me that
over the last maybe 20 years when amer
is elected
they kind of disappear you know you see
more of the mayor in batman movies than
you do in in real life like it's almost
like garcetti got elected and just i'm
not sure where he goes but the mayor
used to be the spokesperson of the city
he would come out and maybe go to lax
when there was an issue or go somewhere
where there was an issue and be the face
and say you know hey we're going to take
control of the situation but i mean
this dude is like m.i.a he goes wherever
the cameras are and i'm tired of hearing
him call everybody angelino's
angelinos are from city of los angeles
i'm not an angelino
i live in the county of los angeles i'm
not angelino and he goes whether it's
the city or not he was just criticized
recently
with the
some kind of promotion they had going at
the new football stadium
over in englewood they were there
announcing and that yet they didn't have
other city council people there
uh there were should have been there
right and yet
garcetti was there and has nothing to do
with city los angeles right
father's day is coming up we got a lot
of hairy fathers out there and so our
friends at manscaped are back tell us a
little bit about what they got going on
so manscape is designed with fathers in
mind and their latest the performance
package 4.0 is here just in time for
your pops and all the pops is out there
special day inside this package you'll
find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer crop
preserver ball deodorant crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs i love
those
and a travel bag to hold his goodies
first off let me start by saying the
lawnmower 4.0 will be the official mvp
of father's day
their fourth generation trimmer features
a cutting edge ceramic blade get it
cutting edge cutting edge ceramic blade
to reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced skin safe technology and
the lawnmower 4.0 is waterproof and also
has a 400k led spotlight he needs for a
more precise shave we all know dads love
their comfort and with summer just
around the corner the boxers 2.0 are
also here to save every father from the
uncomfortable heat down there
so if you want to get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code omg hi at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
omghi
shake what your mama gave you nah shake
what your daddy gave you
but remember this so george
the uh when they when the city of la
voted on charter reform
they kind of spayed and neutered the
office of mayor to a degree and they
shifted a lot of power to the city
council
so that kind of lowered the ability of
the mayor to be the chief executive and
run all the city departments right so
now you got 15 little mini mares
right and one ceremonial big mayor so it
didn't really help the situation no he
has no power i don't think he has the
power if you have 15 little mini mirrors
right you can't
how much power did mark ridley thomas
take away from the city
oh well there's the prime example right
there and now you got people like mike
bonang on one side of the coin and then
you got joe buscaino on the other side
of the coin
one place has lapd doing everything in
their district and the other one lapd
has been told to stand down and just not
do anything
and the residents are losing their mind
over it yeah are you joe buscaino when
he was a police officer
um where does he stand in the in the
whole does he want does he was he not
running to be mayor of valley
he um he um
quit the race itself his name is still
on the ballot i believe but he endorsed
um caruso for mayor
he just announced that about two weeks
ago he
his name is on unfortunately they're
already printed up so his name's gone on
the ballot but he is now endorsing rick
caruso so so when when matt reading was
uh was mayor he was i think maybe a
billionaire a businessman who became
mayor of los angeles um almost in the
same vein as rick caruso would be if he
became mayor
of uh los angeles is it um
why would a guy who
who has so much uh money
and freedom of that of his
being a businessman want to become the
mayor of los angeles
i think it's pretty simple he
he lives and breathes la he's part of la
his entire fortune is invested in an la
if there's no future in l.a it becomes
some dystopian universe where every day
looks like the movie the purge well
that's not exactly gonna benefit anyone
including him so i think he's taking on
a bigger role that probably needs to be
done do you believe that yes i do okay i
do
so he would be i mean
i mean uh who's right he's running
against um
karen bass karen bass and and they've
just
uh karen bass who was there now publicly
one of the campaign thing anti-campaign
slogan she was involved with usc
and the thing that mark gridley thomas
was indicted for
she's also alleged to have received
money from them but not under indictment
but she's involved in that
that's his biggest opponent
does she have does she have momentum in
this race does she have a possibility of
winning
i think she hit a hard ceiling
and i don't think she's going to go past
it because she's too associated with the
status quo and garcetti
and i don't think she's going to
convince people more than
preserving the status quo which no one
wants so i think that's that's her role
to overcome
the
biggest thing sweet alice and uh
who's sweet alice sweet alice is a
local uh activist in
la from what's who is that uh she's a
she's a lady that has been there she's
82 years old she's been a do-gooder for
the city that's not the lady that was at
the dodger games playing the tambourine
in the 70s no no no no sweetheart
and snoop dogg sweet alice came out and
endorsed
rick caruso and snoop dogg came right on
tv with her and said hey
she's been embedded in this community
she's done everything for the people
here if sweet alice is endorsing him i'm
voting okay good snoop dogg sweet alice
two locals this you're not talking about
big politicians you're talking real
people
and they're coming out and i think it's
probably the best thing that
hit the airwaves yet
yeah alex
it has to it has to trip you out man
that i'm pretty sure that not every
person who's a sheriff has
the goal to become you know the the man
in the department
but as you as you've come up in law
enforcement it has to trip you out that
when you finally get a chance to be the
guy that everybody is more concerned
with you than they are with the issues
in the city
yeah it's kind of a disconcerting
you know to see how as it unfolds but
growing up i saw
block i saw baca in fact i held back to
get
elected back in 98
and i saw how he squandered
you know the goodwill coming into the
office he was just misled
surround himself with the bad people gil
can tell you about that
and then we go to
mcdonald
and then people trying to unseat baca so
i helped people try to unseat back after
his thing went sour i helped olmsted try
to win outright when the seat was open
14 so
you know the saying is you know if you
want to do it right you got to do it
yourself so here we are
um yeah exactly i believe that and you
know
um i wish more people in it just overall
weren't as uh
weren't as hate i don't say hateful man
we're as hateful and as and as negative
as we've become you know politics
was
you didn't discuss religion and you
didn't discuss politics and in uh people
they used to say if you don't have
anything nice to say don't say anything
but social media has created
vipers out of kids
out of people out of everybody and i
would hate to think that to live to be
this old 62 that
looking back
things didn't get better
when i left san fernando high in 1979
that they got worse and looking back
that we would be so hateful to each
other
so hateful of of our communities of
politicians and not believe that
every day that you live in your city
that that city could get better if just
people had a better overall attitude for
their neighbors and for the police
officers and for people who
unfortunately
are living uh on the streets and just
you know everyone overall it's it's so
bad man you know i live in a
neighborhood where yesterday this lady
was coming up the street older lady and
i was coming down the street and usually
when people move out of the way they
would kind of wave this lady man would
have if i would have stopped in front of
her she would have
we'd still be there in a standoff i'm
sure and you just feel it coming from
the cars and coming from the people that
there's not just this kind of good will
towards citizens that is really very
very bad out there
i believe social media gives people the
ability to say whatever they want
without having to be responsible for
their actions they can do whatever they
want they're hidden
they're no longer having to respond to
anybody they just say whatever they want
and they're not being held responsible
uh yeah exactly i mean i got out of
politics i mean i helped obama in 2008
and then i kind of wasn't really happy
with the way he was going and 12 i did a
little bit but not so much and you know
that's all people want to tell me is
that i don't do anything for
my own people
i don't uh i made a mistake endorsing
biden that i'm an idiot for
helping obama and that i haven't done
anything for the latino community that
i'm only concerned about myself
you know it's like hey
i'm just a guy who started writing jokes
on a gas company envelope i'm not a
elected official if you like me like me
and if you don't like me don't like me
people say you made a mistake by
allowing me on your show
that was grand you said you'd keep that
in confidence
if i tell you what you know george
remember everyone's everything gets
filtered down into the stupid phone
literally if they can swipe it on the
screen they see a screaming headline no
one bothers reads even the article or
the second line of an article
that's too much misinformation it's so
easy to manipulate when when my
grandmother was living and antonio
villaraigosa was running for mayor the
first time
and james hahn did a
commercial of someone smoking
crack in the dark and it was a james
hahn commercial against viragosa
and i went over to my grandmother's
house and she says
and one thing my grandmother did tell me
from the time i turned 18 was to vote we
voted in every election and my
grandmother said i'm not going to vote
for the mexicano because he smokes crack
and i said what
and she says yeah i saw him on tv that
he smokes crack i said no grandma that
that's a political ad
and you couldn't convince her that
antonio river go so wasn't on the pipe
and i think elderly people who live
when they see those things and don't
read the articles don't understand that
those things are generated by an
opposing political party
yeah in fact now i have a flyer
that has me given the middle finger
to la county and they did photoshop
these photos
and it's a real elaborate and it comes
from oakland
from a group that put george gaston into
office
yeah and this is how they play the game
that's how they play the game and
yeah let's talk about guys going how
does how
um what is his background the first
let's start what is his background then
we'll talk about him as a d.a
well i know he uh immigrated his family
from cuba
worked his way over became an lapd
officer he was on the fourth i know like
28 years or something
and then he switched over became the
chief of police of mesa arizona i got it
right yes and he he tried to become the
chief of police of lapd and didn't make
it
when they were getting ready to point
one and he was in the running he did
megan that's and that's when he ended up
leaving
then he winds up in san francisco
courtesy of gavin newsom who recruited
him to go to san francisco i think it
was to be chief of police or d.a chief
of police
hmm
and then he switches over to d.a he goes
to law school at night
becomes uh becomes an attorney but
doesn't practice law
and then he becomes the d.a of san
francisco and then it all starts
unraveling on
all of his experiments
with uh
you know criminal justice reform
and the city of san francisco just fell
apart now it's looks like one big crime
scene you should put yellow tape around
the whole city of san francisco
call it a day
man that's really that's unfortunate
isn't it yeah
um and the things we've had to do here
recently
unfortunately and tragically when an
off-duty lapd officer lost his life
in the county area
because of the lack of confidence a lack
of trust in mr gascon
mr villanueva made sure that when the
suspect was arrested the case is
supposed to be filed locally not
[Music]
when in available it's a death penalty
case and so the feds took it over
uh the people from lapd the
as i call them
all of us at this level were all the
working swine they applauded the actions
of the sheriff's department picked up
so many
followers for
the sheriff and they're doing it and i
just understood that
the
i want to say
the d.a and maybe ventura county
there was a 17 year old kid that uh
gascon would not file as an adult
and they took it over they filed it
and they're going ahead they're going to
ser their he's going to serve time
as an adult
as opposed to getting out
now that case is actually george that
case is even it's not it's like more
than that
as a 17-year i think two months or two
week 17 years 11 months two weeks he
moles and sexually assaults a
ten-year-old girl in a denny's
restaurant he goes on the run for years
during that time he goes through a crime
spree in three different states
dna evidence catches up to him he gets
arrested now he's 25.
now gaston is a d.a
and he wants to file the charges in
juvenile court instead of trying him as
an adult
at the same time as this unfolding
he has the guy as soon as he was
arrested he became hannah overnight as
soon as the handcuffs were on his name
was james before that
so now he's hannah
now
gaspon puts him in female juvenile
detention facility
and this guy is a multiple you know
violent offender
predator
and now kern county arrests him for a
murder that happened several years ago
and just yesterday he was held to answer
it was actually was current county
at the da's office they got him held the
answer on a murder charge for a crime he
assaulted and killed a fellow homeless
person in current count i think back in
2018 or 19 something like that so the
law caught up to him now he was also
they have recorded him talking to his
dad making fun of us going in la county
hey these guys are going to let me out
they're going to hold me for two more
months then i'm going to get out of jail
that's all they got wow
yeah and how did that go how did
enforce
penalties and crime
you know that's the million-dollar
question right there because as soon as
the very first day he took office he
talked about reform the george floyd
murdered happen so everybody was all
buzzing about criminal justice reform
defunding police was popular in liberal
circles so he shows up his first day in
office he comes down like moses from the
mountain with the tablets his special
directives and said this is the law of
the land now and of course his own
department said what are you talking
about we have to hold people accountable
yes so the clash started his first day
in office
wow even his own people they file
lawsuits against him uh it's just been
so tragic uh a good friend of mine his
father was killed in the line of duty
with englewood
uh the suspect was coming up for parole
recently gascon would not send any
representative from the da's office to
the parole board hearing to fight to
keep him in custody fortunately there
was a captain from englewood police
department
that did go down there
and represent that man and so now the
guys remains in custody yeah uh it's
just tragic what what i've seen after
all these years
in law enforcement that i've been part
of and now to watch this kid it's
killing me how does a writer like
gustavo ariano zero in on you and just
become so obsessed with you that he's
churning out these articles
really only about you
well i i said he used to have an article
in orange county rest um register was
called ask a mexican so i said it should
be called asco vendido because that's
all he's done he's a designated times
if you need to bash the latino let's go
gustavo is our go-to guy
and he he does that with relish he won't
talk about anybody else but latinos
oh yeah he talked about me
there you go saying i'm not birth to
people yeah i mean i'm sure a lot of
people talk about people i was like why
would this guy say these things about me
when
i don't know
but yeah you see it and um
you know
i i saw a video you know i'm from san
fernando and i saw a video of that of
the ship you know the guy swung on the
sheriff right he was being led
underground there and they swung on
which i believe he was the he turned
around and swung at the sheriff and
you know they they traded a couple blows
they got him down on the ground
and uh they put their i think the guy
had his knee on his head
which is probably maybe a a restraint
that they use right i mean you want to
want to
i mean not the neck but
i mean i don't know i i don't know
either because i'm no longer with the
department i don't know what their
policy is i don't want to speak to their
policy but if you control the head you
control the body
that's what i would i don't care what
what quality you control the head you
control the body
yeah that's just physics
i'm sure people would not
who were listening to this or watching
this would say how can you
say that it's not but i mean there are
restraints that are used in
properly and there's restraints that are
used improperly
and um
uh should that inmate have been
handcuffed you think i know he wasn't
handcuffed oh that well the inmate
assaulted the deputy i think he punched
him three times yeah i do yeah i think
he needed to be taken down he needed to
be restrained and handcuffed now that's
why we have investigations to determine
whether or not he acted properly we
don't make assumptions based on videos
we have to do a thorough investigation
we have to ask all the people what were
you trying to achieve were you aware of
what you were doing
and all of this but the people wanted to
jump to the gun because they think it's
george floyd part two and it's just a
false narrative right
yeah
sounds good to me i mean
yeah i mean um you want to say that
it's just that i i just think that when
people see something
well i don't know i mean i don't know
how to say it i don't know how to say
that
i think we're fixed on what we see first
and not what we know
i mean i think people are fixed on what
you see and not what you
what you know is true
and not just about that i just think
about everything
if somebody's in a coffee shop and you
hear somebody talking about somebody and
then somebody says who are you guys
talking about and they say who it is
they might say yeah i did i didn't hear
that but or say i believe that i mean
not nobody it's almost like no one has
their own
individual idea anymore in its simplest
form in my mind the analogy i use is
when i was a kid growing up
if the school called or something
happened in school
and my parents found out it was my fault
yeah and they're not going to run and
blame the school
today
anything happens to kids in school and
they run in the first to blame is it's
the school's fault for not taking care
of their kids you know it's their their
fault
in days of old
you messed up with the cops it's your
fault today
because of even before just before
george floyd
everything that goes on with
these now
cameras on everybody with their phones
it's the cops fault and you see it and
yeah i know what's happened to me before
and the guy pulled me over and he was a
chicken [ __ ] you know the way they
treated me
everything's now is the cop's fault
and
who are you going to call
when you're in trouble right
that's what i we what uh you're probably
very familiar with that phrase oh no you
know not my son right and actually he'll
see and people just don't want to
believe it but i from what one thing i
learned from school going to the
graduate school is you got to be able to
ask yourself the question how do you
know what you know
and then find out okay where does
information come from how credible is
the source
and then when you start picking apart
you dig a little further you realize
okay i'm being pulled along here or
there's merit to it but make the
decision yourself not that someone is
spoon-feeding you you're just going to
slurp it up like a faithful puppy
what would you say to
people out there that
are possibly thinking about becoming a
law enforcement officer but
uh maybe because of the times might not
you know
uh
it might it might hold them back i mean
i know i know that we're underserved but
there has to be people out there who are
qualified to to be officers i'm not sure
if if they're a little bit reluctant of
because of what's going on but
uh in order to recruit
um new officers and deputies they have
to come from some place and you're the
top of the top what would you say to
someone out there that might consider
you know being in law enforcement
well if we can lift the hiring freeze in
la county we're going to hire them and
we have a very good track record of
attracting people but the profession
you're very right george the profession
the profession as a whole is having a
hard time
attracting recruits from the new
generation of kids that are graduating
from high school maybe joining the
military that age group right there 18
20 21
it's not easy because
the media has so demonized the
profession
that people are kind of thinking twice
man is it worth the hassle
to dedicate my career to this but within
the department itself we're in real good
shape now because people want to be la
deputy sheriff so
it's we're kind of an anomaly in that
regard about recruitment side but yeah
for the profession as a whole that is
that is a very big problem
not only is the problem here it's
probably it's a problem everywhere
nationally and and i know
um firsthand my grandson 22 years old
two years ago he was saying i want to
become a cop i want to become a cop and
i said
son what about thinking about becoming a
fireman everybody loves a fireman nobody
loves a cop right now
and he said no my dad's a cop he says i
want to be like you papa nice okay i'm
not here to help you but i'm here to
support you that was his decision
a couple of years later he's decided
maybe that's not for me
and and i was
happy that he made a decision i said
well it's good he was afraid to
disappoint me you're not going to
disappoint me
because if your heart's not into it
you're not going to be a good cop anyway
you know it's better for you it's better
for the citizens this job isn't for
everybody but if you've made that once
you made that decision
you can be
great you just
you've got a heart treat people there
and they're
treating they're training them properly
so all you got to do is remember where
you came from treat people the way you'd
like to be treated and it's a great job
they teach you how to stay safe right
you know so
god bless them and
i'm here to support you but also is it a
is it a bit like it used to be or could
it be where
you know where people in the community
knew i remember i think in in parts of
los angeles they have like breakfast
with a cop is that what it's called like
when you get to you get to have a police
officer come and you can you can ask
them questions about what's happening in
the neighborhood but if you're going to
live in the la county you're going to
have to accept some responsibility for
what happens in the county whether you
leave packages in your car whether you
leave your bike on the porch there's
people out there who are hurting and who
are suffering and who might be addicted
to drugs and they're going to look for
something to to steal to sell but you
can't uh you know you have to accept
some responsibility for
how you live as opposed to just leaning
back afterwards and saying they took my
bike and they took this and they took
that but
you know there has to be a smarter way
to get
to do things in the neighborhood i think
within the last
house
i've seen on my cameras
guys in the middle of the night three in
the morning coming by
checking
doorknobs or car car doors can they get
in there is there anything in there
looking and checking they can get in
that's within the last month where i
live
so they're out there
i have that app on the you know the
right i have the ring door installed
like most everybody does
and on the neighborhood watch the app
they share hey have you seen this guy
and it's always that just like you said
that guy at two in the morning you know
trying to get into cars and going
through the porch and all that stuff so
gotta harden the target for sure
what can people do um all around the
country or around the world to make
their
to make their um
area where they live a little bit safer
for them
everybody has i'm sure ring cameras and
all that but how do we how do we just
open our eyes to things that are out
there that we might not see
well one thing we got to do is we got to
practice the simple rule is don't be a
pandel for starters yeah there's too
much things happening that people are
clueless of that they need to start
looking at in a different light if
you're advertising all the fancy big
screen tvs you have in your house with
the big bay door window open
facing the street while you're
advertising the people hey come take my
stuff
if you're advertising on social media
that you're having that great vacation
in europe that means you're not home so
someone's going to come and clean out
your house and there's things we do
personal safety don't go
a young lady should not be getting gas
at night in the gas station or going the
atm machine if you see someone hanging
around an atm machine he's waiting for
you to get there to pull out cash right
so people just need to be aware of their
surroundings a bit practice a little
more
situational awareness it's going to go a
long way
to improving their safety and same thing
with the mail with email and all that
government only operates by mail and
nothing else we don't call you to say we
have a warrant for your arrest right but
how many people fall for this stuff
yeah yeah they do
they really do i mean that scam
the scam about
fishing or they call it fishing where
they're looking for your information uh
um
the the the guy who climbed up on stage
at the hollywood bowl and ran at dave
chappelle um i know dave chappelle and
his shows like put phones and sacks and
they they seal them up so you can't use
your phone during the show but this guy
had a weapon that i don't think i've
ever seen it looked like a gun but it
had a blade in it
right it wasn't a gun but it was a
gun
looked like a gun but a but it ejected
almost like a a baton a knife
once he jumped on the stage and touched
dave chappelle what's that charge right
there
well right there now you're already at
the point of assault and battery
the moment he uh ran towards him yeah
and that when he tackled him this is
where it's subject to interpretation
i've talked to people that are former
das that say i would have
filed on a felony and it's a
and if a jury wants to break it down to
a misdemeanor that's fine but i'll go
for the felony based on the intent and
the action itself he was armed at the
time i mean there's different ways to
slice or dice it but gaston took the
cheapest route possible because he's
always trying to minimize
uh his exposure to permanent you know
consequences
i mean trying to minimize exposure to
consequence it was done in front of 18
000 people and because it was david
chappelle it was all over the world so
all of a sudden now this is not a felony
and people are saying like
i mean why not so it makes it makes the
city look weak look weak when it's one
guy that that's weak and not all law
enforcement and not this and not
the city it's it's the d.a who's the guy
who is there to enforce i mean that that
guy jumped on stage
and you know ran at him and and
and that and i think even chappelle was
shocked that he didn't
receive a felony he did he complained
about it
yeah and and uh um
i mean with that i mean the security at
the hollywood bowl i'm not sure
is necessarily the tightest because the
hollywood bullets outside i believe even
some comedians that i've talked to uh
were even had even let the hollywood
bowl security know like hey
this guy's not supposed to be right here
and he's been here and he's getting
ready to leap but nobody ever nobody
ever went to him and said hey man can i
see your ticket or you got to go back to
to where you are
and i think he was warned
before that if so even if somebody had
spoken to him it could maybe could have
been prevented
you know by security because there's not
the hollywood bowl has their own
security and i'm not sure how uh strict
they require their their
security to be but clearly with us with
a low stage at the hollywood bowl this
guy was able to to run up there i mean
remember chappelle has the lights in his
eyes and he can't really see what's
going on until the guy's alright right
up right up on him so i think anybody
any performer anywhere would want to
know that if or any citizen would say
that if you're ever attacked by someone
that the d.a can't be looking to make it
a misdemeanor and not a felony
well the sad thing is that you know
they're trying to turn a profit in the
show so
one of the places you cut corners is on
security so you don't hire full-time
cops lapd has a contract with the
hollywood bowl even though it's a county
facility lapd has a contract however
they're relegated to the exterior and
only if the private security raises
their hands and says hey we got a
problem
then they're not involved so by design
but so the screening of people coming in
with metal yeah that's private security
the security around the stage private
security
and
i think tighter security could have
prevented this
but that's an issue of the operators of
the bowl the venue really it falls on
their shoulders
i remember when unfortunately you know
kobe bryant was a friend of mine in ggs
i grew up that that that day in january
that the
accident happened
you were the first person to speak you
were at the site
but also you said that
you grounded the sheriff's the sheriff's
helicopter that day
and you know that day in uh with the
2020
that the whole
january maybe 22nd or whatever day in
january every day was clear in the
morning
except that day
it was the first day it was really
really really very overcast
um
why would a pilot fly that day
why would why would a helicopter get in
the air and not file a flight report
because a flight report tells everybody
that you're going to be in the air
right
if you file and you say i'm going to be
in the air
yeah they they file a flight plan before
they leave and uh
i've been in the air in the vicinity
with with our helicopter pilots and
they've explained to this all was
operator error
that there were specific rules when
there's visual flight rules
and there's things you don't do but his
desire to get his client from point a to
point b
with minimal hassle he could have landed
at van nuys airport i think was the the
default place where he should have
landed it would have avoided the whole
mess
and then i'd rather be inconvenienced
than you know flying to hillside at 160
miles an hour so that
unfortunately that's human human error
right there
you know i know that he got to almost
where the la zoo is and then circled for
half an hour because he didn't have a
planet the guy you could hear the guy
saying hey you know i got planes coming
in man you gotta like hold
uh and he did circles around kind of the
zoo area and then tried to get to the
next place then when he passed van nuys
um
you know i've gone and i think arsenio
as well you know arsenio lived in that
area and he and that morning he sent me
a picture of
his backyard
and his front yard and he said every
morning i could see my gate and you
couldn't see anything and even in that
area by
is that it gets
like a bowl it gets really foggy and
even if you're in a car all of a sudden
you're clear and then you go in there
for whatever reason that that area has
been carved out of it just becomes this
maybe two mile by two mile thing of of
just you of just soup and like you can't
see where you're going i'll tell you
right now there's nothing more
frightening to me when i was in vietnam
a couple of times we ended up going
into the clouds like that and the fog
and there was nothing more frightening
to hear one pilot or tell the co-pilot
co-pilot tell the pilot
you take over i got vertigo because you
literally can't see
and you can't feel and you don't trust
your instruments
and we're there and we're looking and
it's the scariest feeling in the world
and and it's and um
i mean you're within seconds of having
to make a decision and if you get a
little bit
uh what do they call it the uh spatial
uh thing but you're you're orientation
disorientation and you don't know where
you are
i mean it happens to
the best pilots i think i'm not sure i
mean i think they took that same flight
the day before the day before was the
day before it's not that day
and that day was was extremely uh awful
conditions to be up in and also
you know that helicopter did not have
the
up-to-date system of you know terrain
and all the things that would have would
let you know from all around you that
you were you were in an area that you
needed to either go up on you know
yeah he did not have the ability to fly
by instrument without having the visual
and uh our we have an aircraft for two
but one that's a rotary wing our air
five
they can fly through that but that
requires a pilot a co-pilot and all the
instrumentation they have to read
everything and they're sometimes stuck
doing rescues in those conditions
but they have
definitely two ot two sets of eyes
instead of one and they have the full
instrumentation panel that they can rely
on to do that safely then of course
six-wing aircraft do it like nothing
with autopilot like our king air
or big jet liners do that where they go
through cloud blanks like nothing
and uh but man helicopter
that i i take my hat off to helicopter
pilots it's such a busy thing because
you're using your left hand your right
hand your both feet your eyes
instruments the horizon it's
it's a full-time job you cannot rest at
all you know for a while for a while it
looked like um
every person was going to have a drone
and it looked like drones were going to
become the
eyes in the sky
and that you heard that amazon was going
to deliver by droning and check this out
i even saw
i saw
i saw a robot
like walking down western i think it's a
delivery i've seen those does it make
sense that it's a delivery robot you've
gotten one of those before
oh i saw one on 9th street in downtown
l.a went by it had six wheels
and a little flag and it was delivering
food
i mean that's
that's pretty amazing
don't do that that is until the homeless
person just pushes it over and then
then it ends up in the uh uh but drop
but drones uh the the the restrictions
on a drone must be um really really a
lot of them to to to know that
as citizens of whatever city you're in
you don't see drones in the air very
much anymore
no there's a lot of restrictions you
have to comply with there's a ceiling
you can't operate past you can't be near
large venues and you know transit
corridors a super bowl for example we
had a huge area there's no drones going
to be allowed and we have the ability
with the fbi in the fda to ground all
drones we send a message to the drones
that forces them all to go to the ground
wow so
a lot of counter measures because they
pose a serious threat
yeah they do they do
all right well listen man i i uh i'm
appreciative that uh
that you've come on the show
um and that you uh
you know are here with us i i don't know
you personally i've never met before but
you know we talked for a while and and i
have to say i i admire you man i admire
you that you that uh you stand up to uh
everybody and that
you know that uh in los angeles is
it can be a better place to be and and
that you're one of the people that's
trying to make it a better place to be
and you know where i stand sheriff all
those that are listening i hope you
support we're there
and
uh we'll be celebrating
well thank you all i appreciate george
and gill and mr producer thank you for
the opportunity we're i'm just trying to
make la livable for everyone and that's
my focus entirely beautiful
all right alex thank you boss maybe
we'll see you thursday i think
yes
all right whatever you got it right on
all right
you